[Musique]
la flambée des prix des produits
alimentaires c'est donc le sujet chaud
de cette autonome avec une inflation à
9,9% en septembre
avec nous expertes des produits de
grande consommation chez lyrie 10%
d'inflation sur l'alimentaire ce sont
les chiffres de ligne c'est je crois que
ce sont également les vôtres c'est du
jamais vu de voir comme ça des prix
alimentaires qui flambent deux fois plus
rapidement que l'ensemble de l'inflation
oui alors c'est du jamais vu en tout cas
c'est du ça fait longtemps qu'on n'a pas
vu ça pour monter au milieu des années
80 pour avoir des taux d'inflation aussi
importants mais effectivement des
inflations comme ça c'est assez inédit
et c'est pas neutre du coup l'origine de
cette flambée ce sont on le sait bien
les pénuries qu'est-ce qui manque le
plus aujourd'hui dans les rayons
évidemment il y a la moutarde l'huile de
tournesol tout ça on le sait c'est la
faute de la guerre en Ukraine c'est à
cause de la guerre en Ukraine oui alors
c'est peut-être pas aussi simple que ça
mais
aujourd'hui pour expliquer pourquoi les
prix augmentent comme ça dans les
magasins il y a effectivement vous avez
raison un effet de matière première il y
a des matières la lumière qui manque ou
qui sont devenus très chers les cours
des produits alimentaires sont bien plus
élevés aujourd'hui qu'ils ne l'étaient
il y a un an mais ce qui fait la
particularité de la situation actuelle
c'est que c'est pas qu'un sujet de
matière première agricole c'est-à-dire
tout en ce qui compose le prix d'un
produit que vous allez acheter dans un
magasin tout est plus cher la matière
première épluchère l'emballage est plus
cher l'énergie pour produire ce produit
que vous allez acheter et beaucoup plus
cher l'électricité le gaz les transports
pour promener un produit d'un endroit à
un endroit B et plus cher les salaires
aussi augmentent donc tout ce qui
composent la valeur d'un produit
aujourd'hui coûte plus cher à la
production donc ça se retrouve dans les
prix à la consommation et parfois aussi
avec des pénuries ce qui va falloir
s'habituer désormais à manquer de
produits dans nos rayons est-ce que
c'est la fin de l'opulence comme on l'a
toujours connu jusqu'à présent alors
vous avez raison ces derniers mois ces
dernières semaines notamment il y a
beaucoup de produits manquants dans les
magasins donc bien sûr on a cité l'huile
la mayonnaise la vinaigrette parce que
tout ça nécessite de l'huile de
tournesol et aujourd'hui il y a plein a
pas de raison pour lesquelles il manque
des produits dans les magasins soit
parce que la matière première manque
c'est le cas de la moutarde soit parce
que la matière première est très chère
donc il faut pouvoir l'acheter soit
parce que les emballages manquent ou
tout simplement on n'a pas d'étiquette à
mettre sur son produit donc on peut pas
le mettre dans les magasins le
transporteur est pas là donc le produit
peut pas être acheminé et puis cette
multiplication d'incidents climatique
comme on parle on a eu cet été beaucoup
de sécheresse qui a moins de risques les
récoltes et qui font que les produits à
un moment donné vont être difficiles à
fabriquer parce qu'il manque des
produits donc exactement
je pense qu'il faut s'y faire oui il
faut en tout cas se préparer avoir des
produits disparaître parce que au-delà
des problèmes de matière d'emballage etc
les coûts de production sont tellement
en croissance que pour certains
industriels se posent la question tout
court de produire c'est à dire que comme
les prix à la consommation augmentent
pas au même rythme que la hausse des
coûts de production parfois produire
c'est plus intéressant il faut il faut
arrêter de produire donc oui je pense
qu'il faut
une fois dans ce contexte d'inflation et
de d'accident climatique qui se
multiplient et qui impacte les récoltes
s'habituer au fait que certains produits
vont manquer ponctuellement dans les
rayons des magasins pourrait commencer à
manquer alors c'est vrai que la collecte
de lait va être moins bonne que l'année
précédente alors il y a deux raisons à
ça déjà le fait qu'il y a de moins en
moins de bêtes voilà le cheptel le soit
pour faire de la viande ou du lait se
réduit en France et puis effectivement
la sécheresse de cet été qui fait que la
collecte va être plus faible moins riche
en matière grasse également donc voilà
moins riche en matière grasse qui peut
avoir un impact sur sur d'autres types
de produits que le lait mais
effectivement tout ce qui va être à base
de produits laitiers va être en tension
dans les semaines à venir donc beurre et
crème aussi pourrait manquer pour les
fêtes de fin d'année enfin si on pousse
un peu le je sais pas si pénurie ça il y
a un faut faire attention il y a un mot
qui sa panique un peu il faut il faut
faire attention à ce qu'on dit parce que
pénurie ça va engendrer chez les gens
un phénomène d'achat de panique qui va
aggraver le problème donc nous on parle
plutôt de rupture c'est-à-dire pendant à
certaines périodes il manque des
produits mais jusqu'à maintenant les
produits sont toujours revenus si on
prend un peu de recul on voit qu'il y a
des disparités intéressantes à la fois
entre les enseignes mais aussi entre les
marques comment on explique le grand
écart comme ça d'un distributeur à
l'autre c'est vrai qu'il y a un grand
grand écartérial il y a toujours eu des
écarts dans la distribution française là
il y en a plus qu'avant c'est à dire que
avant nous on suit l'écart de prix entre
les deux enseignes les plus chères et
les moins chers avant le retour de
l'inflation cet écart était globalement
de 15% aujourd'hui il est quasiment du
double voilà c'est à dire que cette
compétition sur le terrain du prix pour
garantir les prix les plus attractifs
aux consommateurs elle est exacerbée ça
veut dire que toutes les enseignes ne
répercutent pas l'inflation au même
rythme et dans la même ampleur c'est ça
que ça veut dire chacun sa politique de
prix exactement en fonction de ses
intérêt
bon on imagine que les premiers prix
évidemment et les marques distributeurs
sont de nouveau recherchés par les
consommateurs ça paraît évident et la
question que ça pose c'est ce qui a pas
une espèce de descente en gamme des
consommateurs
c'est ça c'est à dire si vous voulez
quand il y a de l'inflation les
consommateurs ils ont de réactions
possibles parce que tout le monde ne
peut pas encaisser plus 10 % de hausse
de prix sans rien faire quelque part
donc les adaptations elles sont de deux
ordres soit on va mettre un peu moins de
produits dans son panier soit on va
acheter des produits on va descendre en
cam donc acheter des marques moins
chères sur le sacrifice sur les produits
en quantité on le voit assez nettement
sur les fruits et légumes la viande le
poisson des produits qui sont
relativement chers et en forte inflation
ça ça sort un petit peu des caddie et
puis de l'autre côté on voit
effectivement une partie des Français
qui se tournent vers des produits qui
coûtent moins cher les premiers prix qui
sont des produits qui jusqu'à 6 mois en
arrière avait pas tellement ni la faveur
des distributeurs dans les rayons ni des
consommateurs dans les paniers ce sont
les seuls produits aujourd'hui la
consommation se développe c'est toutes
les gammes entrées de entrée de gamme
sur le l'huile de tournesol sur le riz
sur les produits de base on se tourne
versé produits premier prix
on s'attend à quoi dans les prochains
moisisses et table sur une inflation de
12 % d'ici la fin de l'année sur les
produits alimentaires aussi oui
alors à quand le pic honnêtement c'est
extrêmement compliqué parce que tout ce
qui provoque cette inflation c'est des
choses que personne n'avait prédit la
crise sanitaire la guerre en Ukraine
voilà tout ça est très difficile à
prévoir maintenant l'inflation est
autour de 9% en septembre en octobre là
elle va être de 10 effectivement finira
l'année autour de 11 et on s'imagine que
l'année prochaine on reste sur ce niveau
élevé ou on pourrait rajouter encore
quelques points d'inflation parce
qu'autant ça se tasse du côté des
matières premières ça fait 6 mois que le
prix des matières premières s'atténue en
revanche l'électricité les salaires tout
ça augmente encore et donc possiblement
pour
[Musique]